We've seen a variety of graphics and their visual encodings up to this point.
But we haven't discussed which of these is most effective.
How should we know whether to encode a quantitative variable,
in color saturation, or rather than, say, position?
Fortunately, some passionate researchers have answered this question for us.
In a 1985 paper, William Cleveland and
Robert McGill share the results of a series of experimental user studies.
These studies were designed to compare the effectiveness of
display elements like position, length, angle, and others.
They were trying to see how effective using codings were in terms of
users being able to interpret quantitative information,
that is exact numbers from the graphs.
This paper was the first of its kinds to validate the ranking of
encodings using, empirical evidence and as it
turns out position along a common scale is the most accurate of the encodings.
Color saturation or density on the other hand was less accurate.
For the Gat Minor visualization, this is why the most important variables,
Income per person and Life expectancy were encoded using position.
It's the most accurate of the bunch.
The key takeaway here is that if you want to design effective visualizations,
then you need to understand the rankings of visual encodings and
choose appropriate encodings in your designs.